angin will bereit sein wenn der Krieg
beginnt
die junge Armenierin trainiert dafür
fast jeden Abend hier am Rande der
Hauptstadt jerevan sie will nicht mehr
nur zuschauen seit der Eskalation im
September ist sie sich sicher dass
Aserbaidschan wieder angreifen wird aber
mein Gott jeden Morgen wachen wir auf
und haben Angst dass es eine weitere
Eskalation an der Grenze gab jeden Tag
hören wir von Schießereien an der
armenisch aserbaidschanischen Grenze von
Verwundeten und neuen Opfern
Russland und die anderen Staaten
bezeichnen sich als unsere Verbündeten
aber Armenien kann sich nur auf sich
selbst verlassen
eine militärische Ausbildung hat hier
niemand sie sind freiwillige die im Fall
der Fälle die armenische Armee
unterstützen wollen
kämpfendes längst nicht mehr nur
Männersache findet angien für das
Training an der Waffe gibt die
25-Jährige ihren kleinen Sohn in die
Hände einer Babysitterin
Schwiegervater wo war leitet das
Training er hatte mehreren Kriegen gegen
Aserbaidschan gekämpft und weiß wie
schwer der Gegner zu schlagen ist
besser wie er einfache Bürger ausbilden
desto mächtiger wird die armenische
Armee sein
das stärkt unsere Seite auch bei
Verhandlung
so können unsere Verhandlungsführer
selbstbewusster auftreten
Welt
angins Mann gibt die Kommandos die ganze
Familie im Verteidigungsmodus denn es
ist ein Kampf David gegen Goliath mit
alten sowjetischen Kalaschnikows gegen
eine moderne aserbaidschanische Armee
noch trainieren Sie mit Attrappen
ich werde zu einer echten Waffe greifen
wenn mein Mann mein Vater mein Bruder
und jene Männer die das gleiche
werte-system haben wie ich an die Grenze
gehen
und zwar sobald auch nur 1 cm unseres
Landes unseres Territoriums meine Heimat
dem Feind überlassen wird
von Jere waren wir drei Stunden mit dem
Auto Richtung Süden in die Berge dorthin
wo im September Bomben eingeschlagen
sind
um das zu verstehen hilft dein Blick
zurück seit Generationen bekämpfen sich
Armenier und Aserbaidschaner im
umstrittenen Bergkarabach werfen sie
sich gegenseitig Kriegsverbrechen vor
der letzte Krieg liegt erst zwei Jahre
zurück
dann die Kämpfe im September ausgelöst
durch den aserbaidschanischen Angriff
auf armenisches Staatsgebiet
armenien ist klein eingeklemmt zwischen
seinen Feinden wir können die Türkei
sehen und wenig später sind wir nah an
der aserbaidschanischen Grenze
dort den jamuk lebt narine mit ihren
drei Söhnen in einer Nacht im September
ändert sich ihr Leben schlagartig als
ein Granatsplitter ihr Haus trifft
ich hatte sehr große Angst mit einem
kleinen Kind zu Hause ab dem Moment als
das Glas in Scherben zersprang schliefen
meine Kinder nicht mehr auch die beiden
anderen Kinder hatten große Angst
wie viele Frauen und Kinder verließ auch
narine fluchtartig ihr zu Hause doch sie
kam zurück wie alle hier sie wissen
nicht wo sie sonst hin sollen das Leben
in dieser Siedlung ist entbehrungsreich
Marines Mann hat keinen festen Job sie
selbst ist mit den Kindern zu Hause
wir leben täglich mit Angst in unseren
Herzen wir erwarten jede Minute dass es
wieder anfängt was sollen wir dann tun
da drüben sind sie die Aserbaidschaner
sehr nah sie können uns jeden Moment
Treffen
schon seit anderthalb Jahren gibt es
immer wieder kleinere Angriffe
Nadelstiche inzwischen besetzt also bei
Jan einige Quadratkilometer armenischen
Territoriums
für gemuk einen kleinen Touristenort ist
das fatal die Besucher bleiben aus
Restaurantbesitzer arud fürchtet um
seine Existenz
vor diesem Angriff was er bei gians im
September gab es viele Touristen
wir arbeiteten normal konnten Kredite
abschließend Steuern an den Startzahlen
aber jetzt haben die Leute Angst hierher
in den Urlaub zu kommen wir wissen nicht
was morgen mit uns passiert
für seine Mutter Margarita gibt es keine
Alternative zu Ihrem Zuhause hier die
Familie betreibt das Restaurant seit
Jahrzehnten
es macht mir große Angst hier zu sein
wenn der Topf nur ein wenig klappert
bekommen wir alle sofort Angst aber
wohin soll ich gehen es gibt keinen Ort
wo wir hin können
sie sehnen sich in die aus ihrer Sicht
gute alte Zeit zurück als die
Sowjetunion noch Schutz versprach
e
Russen sie alle haben hier ihren Urlaub
verbracht
Republiken sogar Aserbaidschan
wir waren Freunde lebten friedlich
miteinander es gab keine Feindschaft wir
lebten in Frieden und Freundschaft
heute sind diese Freundschaften
unzuverlässig geworden eine von Russland
verhandelte Waffenruhe brüchig das
spüren Sie hier schmerzhaft der
stellvertretende Bürgermeister bittet
die Welt um Hilfe
[Musik]
jedes Land egal ob Russland in Europa
die Vereinigten Staaten die alle von
verschiedenen Seiten in Verhandlungen
verwickelt sind kann uns helfen
und zwar dabei ein Abkommen
abzuschließen
die Aserbaidschaner zurückziehen
und unsere territoriale Integrität
wiederhergestellt wird
[Musik]
zurück in der Hauptstadt sehen viele die
Nähe zu Russland inzwischen als Problem
als Putin Mitte novemberjahre waren
besucht demonstrieren einige hundert
Menschen für eine Abkehr von der
einstigen Schutzmacht und dem
gemeinsamen Verteidigungsbündnis
ich bin hergekommen um zu zeigen wie
unzufrieden ich mit der Mitgliedschaft
Armeniens in diesem Bündnis bin diese
Organisation hat keine Funktion mehr
unsere Mitgliedschaft ist höchstens
dekorativ eine künstliche Allianz ein
Club von Diktatoren Armenien gehört er
nicht dazu
viele Armenier sind wütend auf die
vermeintlichen Verbündeten Russland aber
auch Belarus Kasachstan Usbekistan weil
sie die aserbaidschanischen Angriffe vom
September nicht mal verurteilt haben
viele Menschen hier wünschen sich
stattdessen eine Hinwendung zum Westen
wieso Armenien allein da steht und nicht
mal Russland hilft darüber sprechen wir
mit tigrant der politische Analyst kennt
die Region in und auswendig
Russian Russland war der wichtigste
sicherheitsgarant in der Region aber
russlandsfähigkeiten haben seit der
Invasion in der Ukraine erheblich
abgenommen und auch seine Interessen in
der Region haben sich verschoben
also versucht Russland jetzt noch
unparteiischer zu sein im Konflikt
zwischen Armenien und Aserbaidschan
fühlt sich dadurch berechtigt oder
befähigt zu handeln
eine geopolitische Situation in der
Armenien kaum gewinnen kann das weiß
auch der armenische Ministerpräsident
Fasching Jan und scheint daher bereit
den ewigen Zankapfel Berg Karabach
aufzugeben eine Andeutungen diese
Richtung treibt ins deperner kehrt der
Hauptstadt der karabachs Zehntausende
auf die Straße
in Jere waren treffen wir rubenne den
neuen Staatsminister von Bergkarabach
oder arzach so nennen es die Armenia er
besteht auf die Unabhängigkeit der
selbsterklärten Republik
die Menschen sollten selbst über die
Unabhängigkeit von arzach von
Bergkarabach entscheiden können sie
haben sich längst eindeutig gegen eine
Zugehörigkeit zu Aserbaidschan
ausgesprochen daher ist die einzige
Formel für Frieden die ich sehe Seite an
Seite aber nicht zusammenleben das
bedeutet dass die andere Seite
akzeptieren muss die einzig mögliche
Option für ein friedliches Zusammenleben
besteht darin dass Bergkarabach nicht
teil also bei Jans ist
Jahrzehnte des Konflikts brachten viel
Leid auf beiden Seiten fast jeder
Armenia jeder Armenierin kennt Verlust
für das kleine stolze Volk gehört die
Angst ums Überleben zu DNA
das schweißt zusammen kaum irgendwo
lässt sich das besser beobachten als
hier einmal im Monat wenn es längst
dunkel ist über Jahre waren bei diesem
Tanzkurs
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Arminia aus aller Welt treffen sich um
ihren Kummer wegzutanzen und ihre
Traditionen zu zelebrieren
[Musik]
diesmal ist doch Seda aus Deutschland
dabei
[Applaus]
[Musik]
alles Teil unserer Kultur ist und ich
finde dass wir in den vergangenen Jahren
sehr viel unserer Kultur auch verloren
haben auch im Volk selbst und ich finde
diese Tänze sind so etwas was uns alles
verbindet auf diese Leidenschaft mit dem
wir diese Schritte machen und alles die
Musik
alle sind hier willkommen darauf legt
der Leiter der Tanzgruppe Wert der Kurs
ist kostenlos
Gage genosian will seine Leidenschaft
weitergeben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was Sie sehen sind Tänze die mindestens
zwei 3000 Jahre alt sind aus
vorchristlichen und oft sogar
heidnischen Kulturen in den Götzen
verehrt wurden
jeder Tanz hat eine mystische oder
kosmische Bedeutung
und auch das gehört dazu Tänze die vor
Kampfeinsätzen getanzt werden der Krieg
ist allgegenwärtig jetzt
Badewasser immer Krieg ist ich wünschte
beide Seiten würden einfach auch sowohl
Ihre Seite als auch auf unsere dass wir
halt den Hass unter regeln weil Hass
bringt ja zum nichts
[Musik]
wir treffen Angie und ihre Familie
wieder sie lebt mit ihren
Schwiegereltern unter einem Dach zu
Hause ist sie nicht die Kämpferin angin
sondern Mutter und versorgerin die
Rollen sind klar verteilt
angin wünscht sich vier Kinder ihr Mann
sogar sechs wenn es um die Grenzen ihres
Landes geht sind Sie bereit einen hohen
Preis zu zahlen wir sind drei Japan das
Nummern auch mein Sohn soll in Zukunft
dem Mutterland dienen
in der Armee
ich sehe ihn als ein Soldaten
unserer Heimat hat
Erfahrungen habe eine ungewisse Zukunft
umgeben von Feinden und Verbündete die
ihnen nicht mehr beistehen trotzdem
hoffen sie dass die nächste Generation
endlich Frieden erlebt
[Musik]